vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le des nains
en croit des attaques djihadistes les
deux dernières attaques ont fait neuf
morts et 12 blessés le pays serait-il la
nouvelle cible de terroristes implantées
dans la région comment comprendre la
réponse du gouvernement béninois
éléments de réponse avec oswald pas de
nous chercheur directeur de programme à
l'école nationale supérieure des arts
la libye aussi dans la tourmente c'est
la deuxième fois que le pays se retrouve
avec deux premiers ministres qui
refusent chacun de céder sa place depuis
l'annulation des élections en décembre
le pays s'enfonce dans la crise
politique les nations unies appelle
toutes les parties à préserver la
stabilité du pays
et nous irons cameroun dans ce journal
pour évoquer les transferts d'argent qui
touche de plus en plus cher aux usagers
avec une nouvelle taxe appliquée depuis
le 1er janvier qui grèvent le budget des
consommateurs reportage à suivre
on ouvre ce journal par la situation
sécuritaire au bénin vous le savez trois
attaques à la bombe artisanale ont fait
au moins neuf morts et 12 blessés parmi
les équipes en charge de sécuriser le
parc naturel w dans le nord du bénin on
retrouve en direct depuis cotonou oswald
pas de nous directeur de programme à
l'école nationale supérieure des arts
mêlés nca au bénin monsieur pas de nous
merci de nous retrouver sur france 24
dites nous pourquoi le bénin est devenu
une cible d' attaque jihadiste est alors
que le pays jusqu alors été considéré
comme un îlot de stabilité
oui je pense qu'on peut continuer la
cause grecque et le pays le démenti de
stabilité même si comme tous les autres
pays d'afrique de l'ouest le pays est
exposé à l'expansion territoriale de la
menace donc quant au risque qui parle
donc du sahel qui il est attesté depuis
un bon moment maintenant que ce groupe
la chercher
à joindre donc l'océan atlantique à
avoir un accès sur la mer et donc à
faire en sorte de trouver des couloirs à
partit donc du nord du bénin à partir du
ténor du togo du ghana ou de la côte
d'ivoire donc je pense qu'on est dans un
phénomène de d'abord d'expansion
territoriale
il faut aussi considérer qu'ils
acquittent même quelques malgré des
progrès que de le bénir affaire avec une
politique intégrée de gestion des
frontières l'a tout de même quelques
vulnérabilités qui sont que pendant
longtemps peiné en tout cas dans cette
région frontalière avec le burkina et le
niger notamment
on a longtemps considéré donc le
benetton n'était pas une cible des
organisations terroristes mais de plus
en plus avec ce quatrième incident cette
quatrième attaque d'ampleur on considère
que oui clairement les des nets une
cible que ce groupe là et je pense que
tu me donnes avec lequel faveur contre
les jardins alors que savons-nous sur
les auteurs présumés de ces attaques qui
frappe le pays les autorités parlent
systématiquement de braconniers partagez
vous cet avis
je pense que le discours public ou
politique évoluée bien entendu en
fonction des informations qui sont
disponibles l'aigle attaque jusque là
n'ont pas été revendiquées par appliquer
les les précédentes dont je pense qu'on
a
quand on regarde le groupe qui opère
dans le sud ouest du burkina et dans
cette zone des trois frontières on peut
s'imaginer qu'il s'agit très
probablement donc de gros patch lui à
qaïda même si avec le chine même si de
plus en plus à nouveau notre
configuration donc de tous les groupes
l'aquitaine à la région mais ce qu'il
faut aussi prendre en compte qu'il faut
prendre en compte ce que on le
braconnier le criminel
il ya des passages ya des passerelles
entre toutes ces identités là jusqu'à la
chaîne des deux terroristes de vous
dédié à 10 donc au fond ce qu'on appelle
dans cette région là un peu les zones de
la brosse ou là où les grands freiner à
ladite donc depuis longtemps quand même
déjà en tout cas depuis au moins les dix
dernières années on sait que qu'il tente
de fédérer donc dans la communauté il
tente de servir également si quelques
conflits locaux entre agriculteurs
éleveurs avec les pêcheurs certain
nombre de difficultés locales chez
laquelle ils desservent pour
ancrer la prévoir c'est les développer
donc les activités criminelles dans ces
régions là mais alors est ce que
justement les tensions intra
communautaires justement dans le nord du
pays est ce que ça peut jouer un rôle
dans l'expansion justement de ces
attaques terroristes
alors je pense qu on sache angèle de
regarder parce que le bénin commis sur
ce point a quand même des ressorts des
ressorts en par rapport à son modèle des
livres entendre on se pense que si on
n'a pas donc bien confie communauté
d'ampleur qui te le fais le lien on a
dit à une radicalisation d'ampleur à une
radicalisation d'un grand nombre donc
défier combattants mais clairement on a
aujourd'hui donc cette fête des
tentatives donc de des filtrations la
vie durable donc si le suisse et
territoires et
voilà c'est serait confiée la leçon
prise en charge donc pas l'état et la
réponse qui sont aujourd'hui apportées
qu'elle soit dutronc débit sécurité du
pont de vie économique et cetera
permettre d'envisager en tant
qu'animatrice de 7,2 de ses ridicules
merci merci aux mâles panneaux en direct
depuis cotonou pour ses analyses merci
beaucoup à vous
la libye elle est elle au bord du
gouffre d'un nouveau gouffre pour une
deuxième fois le pays se retrouve avec
deux premiers ministres après la
nomination de fatigue basharat censé
remplacer abdelhamid débat qui refuse de
céder son gouvernement avec le soutien
des nations unies devait mener le pays
aux urnes en décembre mais les élections
ont été reportées camille nédélec
24 heures après la nomination d'un
premier ministre par le parlement
abdelhamid db bas le premier ministre au
cul nu par l'onu n'en ont pas céder le
pouvoir à son rival il ne cédera le
pouvoir qu'après des élections libres et
démocratiques des élections dont on ne
connaît toujours pas là at
cette feuille de route doit aboutir à
des élections quelles que soient les
raisons les élections étaient repoussées
on ne peut pas faire passer une loi sur
laquelle aucun politicien de 100 ans
donc il vaut mieux ne pas se présenter
aux élections donc je suis prêt ne pas
me présenter
malgré les divisions provoquées par sa
nomination le nouveau premier ministre
faty bachar a dit vouloir réunir un pays
fracturée
le prochain gouvernement sera pour tout
le monde et inclura tout le monde nous
allons tendre la main à tout le monde
sans exception
deux premiers ministres en même temps on
l'ebit la situation n'est pas inédite de
2014 à 2016 le pays était dirigé par
deux premier ministre ivo la libye était
alors plongée dans une guerre civile et
malgré ses troubles politiques c'est
surtout la crise économique qui
préoccupe les habitants
les gens tu appelles les moyens de vivre
le coût de la vie est exorbitant le
budget de l'état se compte en milliards
et les citoyens n'ont aucun espoir tout
n'est que mirage
cela fait un peu plus d'un an que le
pays est en paix mais si tu ne paies
précaire avec une crise politique qui se
creuse
à léo passe au reste de l'actualité
africaine en bref et en images
le danemark va suspendre partiellement
son aide au développement à deux pays
africains le mali depuis le départ
contraint de ses soldats et le burkina
faso en raison de son coup d'état
militaire il faut savoir le danemark
consacrent plus de 0,7 pour cent de son
pib à l'aide internationale
une part parmi les plus élevés du monde
charles blé goudé débouté la cour pénale
internationale a rejeté sa demande
d'indemnisation l'ancien pilier du
régime de laurent gbagbo avait été
acquitté en même temps que l'ancien
président ivoirien pour crimes contre
l'humanité
ils réclament et près de huit cent vingt
mille euros estimant être victime d'une
grave erreur judiciaire est manifeste
laurent gbagbo lui de son côté n'a pas
déposé de demande à ce jour on resta là
et où tiens se tiendra la semaine
prochaine une audience pour entendre les
arguments de deux mini-camps guen c'est
le nom de l'enfant soldat ougandais
devenus chefs rebelles de la lra qui a
fait appel de sa condamnation de 25 ans
de prison pour crimes de guerre et
crimes contre l'humanité
revenons-en à cette affaire terrifiante
qui se passe au kenya dans la région de
kissi quatre femmes âgées ont été
brûlées vivantes au moins d'octobre
accusés de sorcellerie et ce n'est pas
la première fois ou coude et au cours
des deux dernières années 150 personnes
ont été tuées les organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme affirment
que ces meurtres sont souvent comme pour
voler les terres les suspects ne serait
pas condamné elle appelle les
gouvernements à trouver une solution
reportage de caroline qui me sébastien
remy
hélène vient visiter une maison tout
juste incendiés pour la deuxième fois
sept défenseurs des droits de l'homme
soutient les familles de quatre femmes
âgées assassiné au mois d'octobre dans
le quartier il les a forcés à quitter
les maisons et les ont brûlés vivants il
est suspecté d'être des sorcières au
moins six personnes accusées de magie
noire sont violentées chaque mois dans
le comté de qu'ici
la mère de jacqueline on a été victimes
ses voisins l'accusent d'avoir envoûté
leur fils
quand je suis allé dans leur maison
c'est à la sem le père a expliqué qu'il
avait essayé de réveiller ses fils
mais qu'il ne réagissait plus nenê la
mauritanie me patat a été qu'est des
vidéos du lynchage circule sur internet
aggravant son traumatisme
mais malgré la peur jacklin vite encore
au village d'autres ont dû fuir
jeannette se cacher vient demander de
l'aide à l'activiste
selon elle les meurtres ne sont pas
liées aux croyances traditionnelles
c'est dû à des querelles pas à de la
sorcellerie tout ça c'est à cause de
désaccords sur des terrains les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme affirment que la sorcellerie est
un prétexte pour s'attaquer aux femmes
âgées dont beaucoup n'ont pas de titre
de propriété
les meurtriers mise sur la peur de la
magie et espère ne pas être sanctionné
il y avait des anciens du village lors
des meurtres cela nous surprend
notre gouvernement et les gens qui sont
sensibles vous protéger et assister au
lynchage de ces femmes
les ong multiplient désormais leurs
actions pour appeler à une réponse des
autorités les chefs locaux ont refusé de
nous répondre mais préviennent la
communauté il ne doit pas y avoir de
vengeance la justice doit gérer la
situation
il ya différentes façons de résoudre ces
problèmes nous avons la police
l'administration du comté les chefs
locaux et nos bureaux sont là pour ça
rieuse neuf suspects ont été arrêtés
après les meurtres mais les familles des
victimes affirme que certains coupables
sont encore libres en groupes de travail
créés par le gouvernement enquête sur
les causes de ces crimes et devrait
bientôt rendre ses conclusions
allez allons au cameroun à présent où
depuis le 1er janvier les transferts
d'argent sont plus chers le gouvernement
instaurer une nouvelle taxe 0,2 pour
cent sur les envois et retrait un coup
dur pour les usagers et les associations
de consommateurs propose que les
opérateurs de téléphonie supporter cette
nouvelle taxe léo le reportage de nos
correspondants à yaoundé richard nanéma
et stéphanois
comme toutes les semaines dans ce
quartier de douala la capitale
économique du cameroun christian se rend
chez une opératrice pour effectuer des
transactions électroniques
l'opération va lui coûter un peu plus
cher 0,2 pour cent de plus mais il n'a
pas le choix le seul moyen qu'on a
aujourd'hui
d'être plus rapide et plus efficace je
me sens plus utilisé par cette nouvelle
taxe forcément parce qu'il ya à chaque
fois qu'il ya ces facs ajoute c est une
pénalité avec l'entrée en vigueur de la
nouvelle texte depuis le 1er janvier le
flux les transactions a fortement baissé
selon cette opératrice
des fonds
avant
de manquer
c'est vraiment sécher le gouvernement
camerounais espère ainsi collecter 20
milliards de francs cfa un peu plus de 3
millions d'euros pour cette économie
c'est un moyen simple et rapide pour
l'état de renflouer ses caisses mais dan
a pas assez de ressources par rapport à
ses besoins notamment pour rembourser
ses dettes il était donc question que
l'état de recherche
des sources
alimenter ses caisses et là c'est une
source facile une approche décrier les
détracteurs lui reprochent notamment de
pénaliser les plus démunis et de
ralentir le développement de l'économie
numérique
l'activité n'est pas intense qu'à 16
passes ce responsable d'association des
consommateurs propose que la taxe soit
directement prélevé chez les compagnies
de téléphonie mobile nous réseau
l'ensemble des consommateurs ce que nous
avions pensé que nous proposons c'est
que cette taxe soit imputée aux
opérateurs de téléphonie mobile ce n'est
pas leur activité centrale
elles sont supposées vous faire de la
téléphonie et de l'internet
environ 10 millions du camerounais
dispose d'un compte mobile selon la
banque des états de l'afrique centrale
plus de 12 milliards de francs cfa de
transactions électroniques ont été
effectués en 2020 le cameroun
c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis et en particulier de
dakar à ziguinchor en passant par thiès
est partout au sénégal évidemment et aux
lions de la teranga rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]